Film Courage: Without naming names,
can you tell us a story about how
a studio took was it your
script or one of your ideas?
Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor: Which
time? I’m a really big proponent on protecting
your work. I will go on record to say don’t waste
your time or your $20.00 or $30.00 doing WGA West.
It’s a waste of time, it doesn’t do
anything. It’s not going to do what
you want it to do. Spend the extra $25.00 and
go with the USCO (U.S. Library of Congress)
US Copyright office is what that stands
for. The process is just as easy.
The copyrights last forever not five years.
Copyrights cover your legal expenses to defend
the fact that you got ripped off and as we’re
young and naive coming up in Hollywood we tend to
really love to share our work with people and I
always tell people don’t you dare send a script
to anybody until it’s finished and copy written
because it’s too easy the person you are sending
it to could steal it. The person that you sent it
to could send it to a friend who needs an idea or
hey I’m thinking about getting into screenwriting.
Do you have any scripts laying around that I can
look at and kind of use as a model? The easiest
thing for a new writer is to look at somebody
else’s work and just copy it. It’s what happens.
I’ve been ripped of over the years. I actually had
a script get produced by a studio who I’ll
not name. They actually went out and made
the movie. I was a 9 million dollar low-budget
film that they put the money behind to make
and they were dumb enough not to even change
the title of the film or the character names
so I guess whoever brought it to them took
my work and just put their name on the cover
sheet and just did it as is. I had gotten wind of
this when they were in post production and what
you’re supposed to do when you get ripped off
is you let the film come out like let it get on
the books and let the trailers start hitting and
that Monday before the Friday is when you drop it
because they are so vested in this with the
20 million in P&A [Prints and Advertising] or
whatever it is they’re going to work out a deal
with you and instead stupid here knew somebody
who knew somebody who worked at the studio when
I heard it was in post-production I made noise
about it and then the film just disappeared. It
never came out, it was never finished but they
indeed my friend got me a copy of the script.
There was a polish on the script. They kept the
names the same, kept the title the same. I go on
IMDB, it’s still there “unreleased” 15 years later
but it’s just kind of funny that this movie got
made that never even got finished (no release).
So that was one. I’ve had agencies take projects
and give them to show runners days after we meet
on them, sometimes hours after. I’ve had a project
that was packaged by a major agency, then in 2007
when the crash hit my investors backed out.
We were three weeks away from rolling film and
the ’07 recession hit. My investors had to
back out so the project never got made and then
weirdly enough two years later the packaging
agent got a new client who shot pretty much
the same script, wound up making it
into Sundance and doing quite well
and at least they changed the title.
They changed the character names
and the best part was they changed the opening
scene but the rest of movie was pretty much
in step. I don’t make noise about that stuff
anymore and I’ve learned. That’s probably why
I’ve become an independent filmmaker. If I have an
idea that I’m passionate about, I’m not sending it
to you, I’m just going to go make it. That’s where
I’ve gotten. I’m just not going to share my work
with anybody. If there is something I believe in
and want to do, it stays in-house and we’ll do it.
Film Courage: So that’s how
a lot of people do it if they
feel their ideas [scripts] have been
stolen? They wait until the week of?
Shane: Well you will often hear about
a film that comes out and you will hear
writes are making noises that their idea was
taken and that is usually when the film is
coming out and what happens is that you get the
studio or the network so vested in the project,
they’ve completely paid the entire process,
now they are going through the marketing and
P&A [Prints and Advertising] and they’ve committed
a good year (year and a half) to the project
and then all of the sudden it’s coming out. And
you know it’s not common but it’s not rare where
you hear this movie is coming out and there are a
couple of writers who say they were ripped off and
more often than not those stories disappear and
go away and I think if you’re able to prove it,
I always say you have to take copious notes,
I always say have a back-up email address so
anytime you send a script to somebody, you send
it to another address you have. Keep those things,
print them out, save them on a cloud so you
have a track record. If you send a script
to somebody you have a conversation
with somebody, keep a journey “Hey
I spoke to this agent at this agency on this
date about this actor and this project.”
Because you know if you’re ever going to make
noise that you were ripped off you have to have
chapter and verse, copious notes on everything
that you’ve done which ideas don’t cut it anymore.
You have to show that there was an interaction.
Well it’s kind of like the guys who pointed the
finger at Zuck for Facebook, I mean they probably
got two, three, four hundred million dollars.
It was an “undisclosed settlement” but they were
able to prove this guy took their platform and
did something else with it and that you have to
think of the same way. You have to have blueprints
for your work, you have to have detailed journal.
You have to have your communications and when they
were, what they were, who they were with so yes
and copyrighted with the Library of Congress.
Film Courage: So is that true that it’s easier for
Hollywood to just deal with the lawsuit than pay?
Shane: I think everybody likes dealing
with a lawsuit than going through the
painstaking…because everybody
today wants the easy way out.
It’s easy to rip off things, it’s too easy
to take advantage. I know a very prominent
producer who has since passed away so I’m going
to tell the story without mentioning a name,
you know he found a script, he was a very
successful producer and he had been nominated
for an Oscar and found a script from an unknown
writer who wasn’t in the WGA or anything and
basically worked out a deal to pay the guy peanuts
and it wound up becoming a very successful trilogy
and you know just bought and sold the script over
and over until he got it where it needed to go and
you know it just seems like Hollywood is kind
of copying itself anyway. I mean that’s what it
does right? Every story has been told, it’s how we
tell it. You know shark movies are big right now,
let’s make a shark movie. Football movies are
big right now, let’s do a football movie. We
capitalized on that Gridiron Gang. We had We Are
Marshall, we had Invincible, we had We Are Giants,
we had Facing The Giants. Yeah Friday Night
Lights. You had this movement of football movies
and it’s no different. I mean that’s what
they do. Incidentally is the same guy who
took that script for peanuts it turned out
he admitted to me later he was trying to
make Gridiron Gang with another studio and he
never had the rights to do it. So it goes to
show you people will easily take an idea and run
with it and he never had the rights to do it.
You know how do you feel when somebody rips off
your work. I guess the old saying is ‘Imitation
is the greatest form of flattery.’ But when
you’re reading the front page of trades and
a big star is attached to a project that you
walked into an agency or a network you know my
dad always talks about how he had brought in
a script to a studio back in the early ’70’s
and was told that’s not for us and
then years later [hums theme music].
So I learned be careful with your product but
how does it feel when you’re ripped off, it
hurts because you have that, it’s almost if you’ve
ever walked into your house after it’s been robbed
it’s the ultimate betrayal, it’s the ultimate form
of…it’s a violation. I don’t know why somebody
can’t say ‘Hey, kid you wrote a script, it’s
pretty good. The idea is there and we wan’t to
take it and work where we are going to pay you.’
I mean just the deception that happens with these
things and I can’t emphasize enough that we have
to. I mean it feels empty. You look at that time
and most writers especially write things on spec
because one day wouldn’t it be great and then one
day you have a library of scripts that you can
look back and say these ten scripts but each
script takes time whether you are a fast writer
or a slow writer. I know people who spend three
months on a screenplay. I know people who spend
10 years on a screenplay. I know somebody who is
actually on their 30th year on the same script.
I cannot imagine if that got ripped off. I mean
30 years, think about it.I tend to take things
well. I tend to take bad news well so I didn’t
get all wrapped up in it. I said okay lesson
learned. Chalk it up as a life lesson and move on.
Film Courage: Did you get any
compensation for it Shane?
Shane: I never got compensated. There are three
projects that I did (that I created) that got
taken. One was produced into a film that never
came out. The other one went into pretty hardcore
development at a major network with a big
star attached. It never it never did come.
There was another one that it was basically we had
a pretty good timeline and proof that there was
a rip-off and what was interesting was that the
institution (the studio whatever you want to call
it) that did the ripping off had also optioned
another project from us previously. So what they
basically did is they took intellectual
property that they had optioned from us
and put it into another project (a storyline
into another project) that they already greenlit.
Totally separate. They were going to make
that anyway. They were hoping to make ours.
Our’s didn’t really come to fruition so they
kind of grabbed some stuff and threw it in there.
We hired the best of the best lawyers and they
were unbelievable in how they structured this
case and their timelines. At the end of the day
nobody wants to go to court. Nobody wants to sue
anybody. I’m a firm believe in the blacklist. I
know people (and I don’t mean the script side),
I’m talking about people saying we’re not going to
work with him because…and it just got to a point
where you know other deals, other options were
made so…do you get paid for it no. Sometimes if
it’s handled in a certain way and I think right
you could possibly entertain another deal or two
with an institution that would admit that maybe
they wronged you or were upset you felt wronged.
You know optioning another piece of property
for two or three years isn’t uncommon I guess
if you play your cards right. Basically what
happened is they said look you know alright we
did what we did and if you guys want to go through
with it we’re going to bankrupt you in lawsuits,
it’s going to take 12 years to engage, do you
have something else we can option? And you know
they are not going to make it but that’s how they
do it. That’s how it worked on the third (on the
first studio one). They will come up with creative
ways to make you feel or Hey why don’t we give you
a development deal and then we don’t have to pay
you anything. They just take a few gratuitous
meetings with you over the course of two years
and you feel like you got yours you know.
It’s weird. It’s a deceptive business and I think
that is what has driven me. I don’t ever want to
thumb my nose at Hollywood proper. I’ve had a lot
of success in it and thank God for it and hope to
work again in it. I don’t count on it and I don’t
care if I don’t. I went real rogue (independent)
in what I do because I just got tired of dealing
with a machine. I got tired of developing. Fall
in love with an idea, put it together whether
you’ve got eight dollars or eight hundred thousand
dollars and go do it. What’s stopping you? I mean
the next film I am doing we are starting in a
couple of months and it started because a group of
us were sick and tired of sitting around in 2020
and we figured we can toss 2020 in the garbage bin
like a lot of people are or we can show something,
we have something to show for it. And it was
kind of like we know two guys with two great
cameras and a sound guy. We’ve got actors that
want to play. I’ve got a great writer who has
got a ton of material. I’ll direct, produce
and cut the thing for free. I don’t care. Let’s
make this year something. And then it turned into
something where investors have gotten involved and
better actors and bigger actors and crew and now
all of the sudden we have a real movie we’re going
to make and it happened because we just got sick
and tired of sitting around and started putting
things into motion. We never asked anybody for
money. That was the last thing. We just wanted
to get busy and have something to show for
2020 and the next thing you know we’re in full
blown pre-production on a show so I like that.
There is no development, there’s “let’s do it!”
Question For The Viewers:
Which part of this video is most
helpful? How will this impact
you moving forward?